[DIGITAL BLIPS]
STEPHANIE WONG: Regional.
Nearline.
Coldline.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Hey, Stephanie.
What are you doing?
STEPHANIE WONG: I'm
trying to organize
my objects into the
appropriate storage classes.
IVAN RAMIREZ: But why?
STEPHANIE WONG: Because if
I organize them properly,
I could save a lot of money.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Well, that I know.
But why are you doing
them one by one?
Didn't you know you could
automate this entire process
simply by using lifecycle
management rules?
STEPHANIE WONG: Sounds like
you're about to show me how.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Let's
jump right in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If we're talking about
lifecycle management,
we need to have a
clear understanding
of the different
prices and features
that each one of the
different classes provides.
So let's go ahead and go through
a high-level overview of them.
First, we have
multi-regional storage,
which will provide
geo-redundancy,
meaning that it's generally
good for storing frequently
and globally accessed content.
Then we have regional
storage, which
is great for data needing to
be kept in a single region,
meaning that it's
best suited for data
sets that will only be accessed
from a particular region.
Then we also have
nearline storage,
which is meant for
infrequently accessed data.
Here you pay a cheaper
price for storing your data.
But you must also pay
for retrieving it.
The math works out so that
if you access the data less
than once per month,
then you are actually
saving money by using nearline.
And lastly, we have coldline.
The SLAs for coldline
are the same as nearline.
But the price for storing
an object is even lower.
Here we also have a fee
for retrieving the data.
And in this case,
the math works out
so that if you access the
data less than once per year,
you'll be saving money.
Now, lifecycle management
is an easy and simple way
to automatically move
objects from one storage
class to another by simply
setting a set of rules
instead of having to do
the process manually.
The idea is that if you
are not accessing objects
within specific
time periods, there
is a substantial amount
of money that you
could save by taking advantage
of the different storage
classes.
The different rules
by which you could
set these automatic
policies are the following.
Age, Created Before, IsLive,
which is basically just asking
if you have the latest
version, and whether it matches
a specific storage class.
Let's go into the
console now and show you
how easy this is to set up.
So now that we're
in the console we're
going to click on
the burger menu
and go to the storage
section of the console.
Here you'll see a bucket that I
created called Take Five Demos.
And you'll see that no
lifecycle management
rules have been specified.
If we go into the bucket, you
can see a series of objects
that I added and two different
dates about three days apart
from each other, on the 18th
and on the 25th of this month.
Now, we'll go back
to the main page
and actually add some of these
lifecycle management rules.
And click on None.
And we'll go ahead
and add a rule.
Here we can specify the type
of rule that we want to add--
Age, Created By, and so on
that we described earlier.
We'll go ahead and select
Age, and we'll define the age.
In this case, we'll
set it to three.
We'll go ahead and continue,
and say what this rule will do,
which in this case we'll
set the objects to coldline.
We'll go ahead and
save this rule.
That's another example.
We'll go ahead and
add another rule.
This time if any object
is older than one day
it will automatically set
that object to nearline.
Now that we've
setup these rules,
let's go back to our
objects within our bucket
to see how they've
been classified.
Now, we sped up this
process for the video,
but this usually
takes about a day.
Now you can see all of
our different objects
within the bucket.
And you can see that
the storage class
has changed to coldline
for some of them
and regionals for others.
Now, this was a
really quick demo
of how you can use
lifecycle management
to manage your objects.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well, now
that my lifecycle management
is automated, I can
spend much more time
developing cool features.
IVAN RAMIREZ: And with all
the money you're saving,
you should ask for a raise.
STEPHANIE WONG: You're right.
Well, don't forget everyone
to like, subscribe, and share.
IVAN RAMIREZ: And we'd
love to hear your thoughts.
What life cycle
management strategies
would you take on
Google Cloud Storage.
Comment below.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]